ahora tendremos sumas y restas con
decimales porcentajes y fracciones se
vería como algo así realmente se ve un
tanto más complicado pero van a ver cómo
lo separaremos todo y será mucho más
sencillo
aquí tenemos 79 % lo que significa
realmente 79 sobre 100
tenemos también 79.1 que es un número
con fracciones y también tenemos 58
con un décimo
para que esto lo podamos resolver
ocupamos tenerlo en un solo formato
digamos que el más sencillo y el que
estamos viendo actualmente es el de las
decimales
así es que haremos la siguiente forma 79
entre 100
porque esto significa punto 79 porque
estamos en las centésimas ok es como 79
entre 100 ó 79 dividido entre 100 es
igual a punto 79 a esto le arrestaremos
79.1 y 58 con un décimo realmente
significa 58.1 porque estamos en las
decimales una decimal undécimo
ahora todo lo tenemos ya por decimales y
esto lo podremos resolver vamos a hacer
lo mismo que hacemos siempre acomodar
los todos por el número que podemos ver
aquí este punto 79 es más pequeño que
estos números enteros así es que lo que
podemos hacer es multiplicar todo
por menos esto que va a implicar esto
nos va a alterar los signos de adentro y
este se convertirá en menos 79 en un más
79.1 y un 50 y 8.1 porque tiene sentido
porque esto significa menos por menos
nos da este más que tiene menos por más
igual a menos menos por más igual a
menos realmente lo único que hicimos fue
multiplicar por menos para poder tener
mayor facilidad ahora pongamos entonces
79.1
mas 58.1 lo que estaremos haciendo es
esta primera suma para después poder le
restar esto
y sumamos 11 es igual a 2 tenemos el
punto decimal 98 es igual a 17 y
llevamos 11 785 13
137.2 esto lo pondremos aquí 137.2 lo
que estamos haciendo es
y compactar nuestra operación
ahora a 137.2 le restamos puntos 0 79
quitemos entonces menos
punto 79 pongamos aquí 0 y rellenamos
este 0
veamos si hemos de pedir prestado
el 9 sin duda es más pequeño que el 0 de
aquí arriba por lo que éste se
convertirá en un 1 y esté en un 10
10 es más grande que el 9 perfecto ya
podremos hacer la resta sin embargo 1 es
menor que 7 vamos a hacer otra solicitud
de préstamo este 7 se convertirá en 6
y este uno se convertirá en 11 el 6 ya
es más grande que el 0 el 3 es más
grande que el 0 y el 1 sin duda es más
grande que el 0 hagamos nuestra resta
ahora 10 menos 9 es igual a 1
11 7 es igual a 4 y esto es
importantísimo nuestro punto decimal
6 - 0 es igual a 6 y este 3 -0 es igual
a 3 1 - 0 es igual a 1 pero ojo aún no
estamos listos tenemos esta respuesta a
136 1.41 pero nos hace falta
multiplicarlo por el menos de afuera así
es que tendremos menos 136 punto 41
nuestro resultado lo escribiremos en
limpio aquí menos 136 punto 41
ahora saben cómo convertir todos a un
mismo formato y poder hacer de esta
manera más sencillas nuestras sumas o
restas con decimales fracciones y
porcentajes y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo